الميدانيه الاخيره في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا اذا تميزت بالتركيز على جبهه
جديده في الصراع هي جبهه الموانئ فميناء
بالبحر الاسود الذي اعلنت القوات
الاوكرانيه استهدافه هو اكبر ميناء في
روسيا ويعد استراتيجيا للغايه باعتباره
مفترق طرق النقل الدولي بين روسيا والبحر
الابيض المتوسط ومناطق ايضا في اسيا يحمل
هذا الميناء الرقم القياسي للموانئ
الروسيه من حيث طول خط الرسم الذي يتجاوز
ثمانيه كيلومترات وتستمر الملاحه فيه على
مدار العام تقريبا افتتح عام
1845 لاستقبال السفن الروسيه والاجنبيه
القادمه من الخارج وبفضله اصبحت التجاره
البحريه النشاط الرئيسي لسكان مدينه
نوفروسسك روسيا كانت بدورها قد استهدفت
قبل يومين ميناء اسماعيل الاوكراني وهو
احد موانئ الحبوب جنوب غرب اوديسا ويقع
على نهر الدانوب على الحدود مع رومانيا
وادى استهدافه الى تعطيل العمل فيه وتسجيل
ارتفاع في اسعار الحبوب